Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. which brought Mary down. The fact was that an embarrassment had been removed, a problem resolved. There was no doubt whatsoever that Mary could have continued her reign,
感谢收听《历史的 rest is history》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 the restishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，therestishistory.com。正是这一点导致了玛丽的倒台。事实是，一个麻烦被去除了，一个问题得到了解决。毫无疑问，玛丽本可以继续她的统治，
free of the albatross, because that was precisely what people wanted. What she had to do, as Elizabeth and Catherine de Medici, both of whom stood by her in February 1567, begged her to do, was to preserve an appearance of innocence. allow the scandal to burn itself out, enable stability to return. Rulers did recover from great scandals in the 16th century, the Bartholomew's Day massacre, the execution of Mary Queen of Scots herself,
摆脱信天翁般的诅咒，因为这正是人们所期望的。正如伊丽莎白和凯瑟琳·德·美第奇在1567年2月都曾支持并恳求她的那样，她所需要做的是保持清白的表象，让丑闻自行平息，使局势恢复稳定。在16世纪，统治者从重大丑闻中恢复过来是有先例的，比如巴托洛缪节大屠杀、苏格兰女王玛丽本人的处刑，
were headline news in Europe and infinitely more dangerous to their perpetrators than the murder of Darnley. The problem, therefore, was not the murder. It was the infinitely unwise behaviour of Darnley's widow. So that was the historian Jenny Wormald in her biography of Mary Queen of Scots, which has the splendid title, A Study in Failure. She hates Mary, Queen of Scots. So in our last episode, Tom, we described the events leading up to the murder of Mary's second husband, Lord Darnley, who you don't rate as a man.
这些都是欧洲的头条新闻，对其制造者而言，危险性远比达利谋杀案要大得多。因此，问题不在于谋杀本身，而在于达利遗孀极其不明智的行为。以上是历史学家珍妮·沃马尔德（Jenny Wormald）在其苏格兰女王玛丽传记中的观点，该书有个响亮的书名《失败的研究》（A Study in Failure）。她很讨厌苏格兰女王玛丽。所以在上一期节目中，托姆，我们描述了导致玛丽第二任丈夫达利勋爵被谋杀的事件，你在人品上对他的评价不高。
I don't rate him either. We described the murder and we described the suspects and the aftermath. And we went through in true crime podcasting style, going through all the different conspirators and explaining, sort of exploring the moments that led up to the murder itself. And we identified the conspirators, a large cross-section of the Scottish nobility.
我对他的评价也不高。我们描述了谋杀过程、嫌疑人以及事后的影响。我们以真正的犯罪播客风格，梳理了所有不同的阴谋策划者，并解释、某种程度上探讨了导致谋杀本身的那些时刻。我们确认了阴谋策划者，他们代表了苏格兰贵族阶层的大部分群体。
Talk us through them. So some of them have got vendettas against Darnley, they hate Darnley. Some of them there are more coldly political reasons to do with their sense of what's right for Scotland and for Mary. Well, I think, Patrick, reasons, you might say.
给我们详细讲讲他们吧。其中一些人对达利怀有私仇，他们恨达利。另一些人则出于更冷酷的政治原因，这与他们对苏格兰和玛丽利益的认知有关。嗯，帕特里克，你也可以说是出于这些原因。
Right. They wanted to, yeah, they want to do what's right for Scotland. So there are three ringleaders. One of these is William Maitland, who is Mary's Secretary of State. He had essentially first floated the idea for the murder. He'd coordinated the conspiracy. He had liaised with William Cecil, who is Elizabeth's first chief minister and a man who had always wanted Mary's overthrow.
对。他们想要，是的，他们想为苏格兰做正确的事。所以这里有三个首领。其中之一是威廉·梅特兰（William Maitland），他是玛丽的国务秘书。他基本上最早提出了谋杀的想法，协调了策划，并与威廉·塞西尔（William Cecil）保持着联系。塞西尔是伊丽莎白的第一首席大臣，也是一个一直想要推翻玛丽的人。
Then there is the Earl of Morton, pudgy-fingered, and sinister, slow speaking, loves of vendetta, Mary's former Chancellor, just back from England after having been double-crossed by Darnley, very sinister, very vengeful, as we said. And then there is the Earl of Bothwell, who is the Lord who had consistently shown the most loyalty to Mary. He is swaggering, he is violent, he is murderously ambitious, and he is the man who had provided the gunpowder that blew up Darnley's house and people may be wondering
接着是莫顿伯爵（Earl of Morton），他手指粗短、阴险狡诈、说话慢条斯理，酷爱寻仇，曾任玛丽的宰相，刚从被达利出卖的英国返回，正如我们所说，非常阴险且极具报复心。然后是博斯韦尔伯爵（Earl of Bothwell），他是对玛丽表现出最坚定忠诚的领主。他不可一世、暴力成性、有着强烈的谋杀野心，正是他提供了炸毁达利宅邸的火药，人们可能会好奇
what did we decide about Mary if they haven't listened to our previous episode well we concluded that Mary was ignorant of the conspiracy genuinely appalled by Darnley's murder and therefore not guilty but with Darnley gone actually you could argue that things
如果我们没有听上一期节目，我们对玛丽是怎么看的呢？嗯，我们的结论是玛丽对这个阴谋一无所知，对达利被谋杀感到由衷的震惊，因此是无罪的。但随着达利的离去，实际上你可以说事情
looking quite good for Mary so as Jenny Wormold points out it's not just a crime it's an opportunity You know, Darnley was this terrible millstone. He's now gone. And actually, Jenny Wellmore, makes a really good point. Lots of kings and indeed lots of queens in the 16th century sanction acts of shocking violence. So Elizabeth I is a really good example. Or Mary's mother-in-law, Catherine de Medici. And then they use them. They benefit from them politically. There's a bit of scandal. There's a bit of a stigma and stuff, but they ride it out. Why is it different for Mary? And in the last episode, Elizabeth the first wrote to that letter and said, you know, you need to sort this out. And you need to sort it out by identifying the culprit and punishing him. Is that basically the mistake from which Mary never recovers, that she doesn't take Elizabeth's advice?
对玛丽来说正变得相当不错。正如珍妮·沃马尔德所指出的，这不仅是一桩罪行，更是一个机遇。你知道的，达利这个可怕的累赘现在消失了。实际上，珍妮·沃马尔德（Jenny Wormald）提出了一个非常好的观点。在16世纪，许多国王乃至许多女王都曾批准过令人震惊的暴力行为。伊丽莎白一世就是一个很好的例子，或者玛丽的婆婆凯瑟琳·德·美第奇。然后他们利用这些暴力事件，从中获得政治利益。会有一点丑闻，会有一点污名之类的，但他们能安然渡过。为什么对玛丽来说就不同了呢？在上一期节目中，伊丽莎白一世写了那封信，说：“你知道的，你需要解决这件事。你需要通过查明罪魁祸首并惩罚他来解决这件事。”这基本上就是玛丽永远无法恢复的错误吗？她没有听取伊丽莎白的建议？
Yeah, basically. I mean, Elizabeth is right. Elizabeth is a very shrewd operator. She reads the Scottish situation much better than Mary herself does, perhaps because she has distance. but also I think because Mary is a very impulsive woman who is given to acting on her emotional response to a situation rather than trying to stand back and looking at it more coolly. And the reason that Mary refuses to accept Elizabeth's advice
是的，基本上如此。我的意思是，伊丽莎白是对的。伊丽莎白是个非常精明的操盘手。她对苏格兰局势的判断比玛丽本人要好得多，也许是因为她保持了一定距离，但我也认为是因为玛丽是一个非常冲动的女性，习惯于根据自己对某一局势的情绪反应行事，而不是试图抽身出来更冷静地看待它。玛丽之所以拒绝接受伊丽莎白的建议——
that she should come down hard on Bothwell, who everyone by this point is agreeing is behind the murder, I think it's for two reasons. Firstly, Mary doesn't think Bothwell is guilty. Mary has a very clear sense of who she thinks is to blame, and this is her half-brother, the Earl of Morey, who had long been on manoeuvres against her. She doesn't want to go after Bothwell
即她应该对博斯韦尔采取强硬态度——此时所有人都认为博斯韦尔是谋杀的幕后黑手，我认为原因有二。首先，玛丽认为博斯韦尔无罪。玛丽对谁该负责有着非常清晰的看法，这个人就是她的同母异父兄弟、长期以来一直在密谋反对她的莫雷伯爵（Earl of Moray）。她不想针对博斯韦尔，
because she's genuinely convinced of his innocence. But even as she blames Moray, she also believes, and in this she is correct, that a whole swath of the Scottish nobility had also been parties to the conspiracy. And this, I think, has thrown her into a massive funk because she also believes, and in this she is wrong, that she, as well as Darnley, had been targeted by the explosion. And I think it doesn't help her in kind of misreading the situation as badly as she does, that she's physically ill. She seems to have lost her ability to kind of ride out crises.
因为她真诚地确信他是无罪的。但即使她在指责莫雷的同时，她也相信（在这点上她是正确的），苏格兰贵族的一大批人也是该阴谋的同谋。我认为这让她陷入了巨大的恐慌，因为她还相信（在这点上她是错的），除了达利之外，她自己也是爆炸的目标。我认为她之所以对局势产生如此严重的误判，部分原因也是因为她身体有病，她似乎失去了应对危机的能力。
We've seen an example of that before. She behaves very impressively, say, in the aftermath of the Ritsio murder. But on this case, she doesn't. And so the second reason why she refuses to go after Bothwell is that Bothwell is the man that she is looking to serve as her champion. She needs someone she feels who she can rely on. And this isn't just for herself, but also for her infant son, James. Far from a reigning Bothwell, she turns to him and says, look after me, I need you.
我们以前见过这样的例子。比如说，在里乔谋杀案之后，她的表现非常令人印象深刻。但在这次事件中，她没有。因此，她拒绝追查博斯韦尔的第二个原因是，博斯韦尔是她期望作为自己捍卫者的人。她需要一个她觉得可以依靠的人。这不仅是为了她自己，也是为了她幼小的儿子詹姆斯。她不仅没有管束博斯韦尔，反而转向他说：“照顾我，我需要你。”
Be my chivalrous knight. You know, Bothwell is a great man for chivalry, even while he's kind of beating people up behind the back of the pub. He is also very keen on kind of posing a salonsalot. And Mary plays the part of Guinevere, quite damagingly, because the accusation that she's literally been adulterous with him is already swirling around Edinburgh. I mean, why is that a massive problem? Why didn't she, I mean, she could. you could say he's a very violent man, he's a man who will do what needs to be done, maybe, as it were, jumping into bed with him politically, is a smart move,
做我的骑士吧。你知道的，博斯韦尔是个崇尚骑士精神的人，尽管他私下里会在酒吧后面把人揍一顿。他也非常热衷于摆出宫廷情人的姿态。而玛丽扮演了吉尼维尔（Guinevere）的角色，这带来了相当大的负面影响，因为她实际上与博斯韦尔有染的指控已经在爱丁堡流传开来。我的意思是，为什么这是一个巨大的问题？为什么她不——我的意思是，她本可以——
allying yourself with somebody who's going to be feared. Well, we will see what the effects of Mary allying herself with Bothwell will be because the fact that she has turned to Bothwell for her security, this isn't something that she can really keep private. And so in the 40 days that follow Darnley's murder when she is meant to be in mourning for him, she is repeatedly seen in the company of Bothwell. And this does not go down well. It's noted as well that she has made a gift of Darnley's clothes and horses to Bothwell. Again, this can be misconstrued very, very easily.
你可以说他是个非常暴力的人，是个会做该做之事的人，或许，从政治上与他同床共异，是个明智之举，与一个会让人感到恐惧的人结盟。好吧，我们将拭目以待玛丽与博斯韦尔结盟会带来什么后果。因为她为了自身安全而转向博斯韦尔这一事实，并不是她能真正保密的。因此，在达利被谋杀后的40天里，本该为他服丧的她，却多次被看到与博斯韦尔在一起。这并没有产生好的影响。人们还注意到，她把达利的衣服和马匹作为礼物送给了博斯韦尔。同样，这非常非常容易被人曲解。
And then there comes a key development that lots of the Scottish nobility who by this point are worrying, that Mary's partiality to Bothwell may well provide him with the opportunity to establish himself as a kind of military strong man and therefore threaten them all. As part of Bothwell's attempt to provide security for Mary, he installs one of his own henchmen as the captain of Edinburgh Castle. And so this seems, from the point of view of Bothwell's rivals, to be a very sinister development. They don't trust him and therefore they are starting not to trust Mary precisely because she does trust him. There is also a knock-on effect for Mary on her public reputation with the mass of people in Edinburgh and beyond. So that Easter, a couple of months after the
随后发生了一个关键的发展：许多苏格兰贵族此时开始担心，玛丽对博斯韦尔的偏爱很可能会给后者提供机会，让自己确立为一种军事强人，从而威胁到他们所有人。作为博斯韦尔试图为玛丽提供安全保障的一部分，他安插了自己的一个亲信担任爱丁堡城堡的队长。在博斯韦尔的对手看来，这似乎是一个非常阴险的发展。他们不信任他，因此他们也开始不信任玛丽，正是因为她信任他。这对玛丽在爱丁堡广大民众及其他地区的公众声誉也产生了连锁反应。因此，在复活节那天，也就是达利被谋杀几个月后，
murder of Darnley, Mary rides out from Edinburgh Castle, now under the control of Bothwell's henchmen. And there are a group of women in the market at their stalls and they shout to out to her, God save your grace, if you be innocent of the king's death. And this is the first time that Mary publicly hears the accusation that she might be responsible for the murder. And of course it devastates her. And then news comes from Dunfernland that a pornographic placard has been posted there showing a mermaid and a hair and the mermaid is associated with prostitution and the mermaid is shown bare breasted and she is labelled MR, so that's Maria Regina, Queen Mary, and the hare is the heraldic
玛丽骑马离开了现在由博斯韦尔亲信控制的爱丁堡城堡。市场上有一群女人在她们的摊位旁对她大喊：“如果你是国王之死的无辜者，愿上帝保佑您的恩典。”这是玛丽第一次公开听到指责她可能对谋杀负责的声音。这当然让她大受打击。然后邓弗姆林（Dunfernland）传来了消息，那里张贴了一张色情海报，上面画着一只美人鱼和一只野兔。美人鱼与卖淫有关，画中美人鱼赤裸着胸膛，并被标上了“MR”（即Maria Regina，玛丽女王），而野兔则是博斯韦尔家族的纹章符号。
symbol of Bothwell's family. So the implication there is very clear that the queen who was once so loved by the people, so popular with them, is starting to lose her whole. on her subject. And is that because people had affection, even though Darnie was in private, a terrible man? Is that because people had affection for Darnie, do you think? No, I don't think so. I think it's because the notion that their queen might be an adulteress and a murderess is not going down well. Okay.
因此，那里的暗示非常明确：曾经如此被人民爱戴、如此受人欢迎的女王，开始失去她对臣民的掌控力。这是因为人们对达利怀有感情吗？尽管达利私下里是个糟糕的人？你认为是因为人们对达利有感情吗？不，我不这么认为。我认为这是因为他们的女王可能是一个女淫妇和一个谋杀犯的这种观念，并没有被大众所接受。好吧。
They don't like Bothwell. They don't like the queen's association with him. They don't like the fact that Bothwell has very probably killed Mary's previous husband. It just looks very, very bad to them. So on Bothwell, do you think Bothwell at this point, I mean, Bothwell must be thinking, you know, there's a vacancy there and I'm the man to fill it. Yeah, he's clearly very ambitious. He clearly sees Mary's evident affection for him as a massive feather in his cap.
他们不喜欢博斯韦尔。他们不喜欢女王与他的交往。他们不喜欢博斯韦尔很可能杀害了玛丽前夫的事实。这一切在他们看来非常非常糟糕。那么关于博斯韦尔，你认为此时的博斯韦尔——我的意思是，博斯韦尔一定在想，你知道的，那里有一个空缺，而我就是填补空缺的人。是的，他显然野心勃勃。他显然把玛丽对他的明显喜爱视为自己的一大功劳。
But I think also his ambition to take Darnley's place is because he, I mean, better than anyone, is aware that he has an enormous number of enemies and that the higher he rises, the more predatory those enemies are going to become. So John Guy puts it really well. He started thinking in the crudest possible terms that to guarantee his position in the giddy game of noble factionalism,
但我也认为，他想要取代达利的野心，是因为他比任何人都更清楚地意识到，自己有数不清的敌人，而且他爬得越高，那些敌人就会变得越贪婪。正如约翰·盖伊（John Guy）精辟地指出：他开始以最粗鄙的想法去思考，为了确保自己在贵族派系斗争这场令人眩晕的游戏中的地位，
he must physically possess the queen. And of course, this is precisely what people think has been going on. Right. That Mary and Bothwell have been conducting an adulterous fair. I mean, Mary hasn't been, I don't think, but I think Bothwell is now aspiring to win the queen and get her into his bed and marry her and thereby essentially become king. And there's a crucial meeting, isn't there? 19th of April, he gets the other conspirators to a pub, Ainslie's Tavern in Edinburgh. And so is that the meeting where he basically lays out his plan
他必须在肉体上拥有女王。当然，这正是人们认为一直在发生的事情。对的。玛丽和博斯韦尔一直在进行通奸。我的意思是，玛丽并没有，我不认为，但我认为博斯韦尔现在渴望赢得女王，让她上床并娶她，从而实质上成为国王。这里有一个关键的会议，对吧？4月19日，他把其他阴谋策划者叫到了一家酒馆，即爱丁堡的埃恩斯利酒馆（Ainslie's Tavern）。那么，那是不是他基本上阐述自己计划的会议？
and says, you know, I want to marry her? He says, look, guys, if I be able to. become king, then I'll be in a position to look after you all. So why don't you sign up for it? And while you're doing it, perhaps you could also confirm that I'm completely innocent of Darnley's murder. And so not all the conspirators sign it. So Maitland doesn't sign it, but Morton does. And so Bothwell thinks, well, this is brilliant. If I got Morton on side, then, I mean, he's the really dangerous player. I can probably go ahead with this plan. And that is then confirmed for him by the fact that Moray, who is his oldest and most formidable rival, is so alarmed by what's going on that he has fled to France, has abandoned Scotland.
并说：“你知道的，我想娶她？”他说：“听着，伙计们，如果我能成为国王，那我将有能力照顾你们所有人。所以你们为什么不签名支持呢？在你们签名的同时，也许你们也可以证实我对达利的谋杀是完全无辜的。”并非所有的阴谋策划者都在上面签字。梅特兰没有签，但莫顿签了。因此博斯韦尔心想，这太棒了。如果我把莫顿拉拢过来，既然他是真正危险的角色，我大概可以推进这个计划了。莫雷是博斯韦尔最老、最强大的对手，他被眼前的局势吓得逃往法国、抛弃了苏格兰，这一事实进一步向博斯韦尔证实了这一点。
And the news of this makes Bothwell dance for joy. And I can't help but being reminded when reading the story of Macbeth, the man who aspires to the throne, the rival nobleman who flee abroad, the echoes seem very eerie, and perhaps they're deliberate. I mean, Macbeth is written when James I 6th of Scotland becomes. James I, the first of England. So perhaps there's a kind of faint hint of a shadow play there. I don't know.
听到这个消息，博斯韦尔高兴得手舞足蹈。读到这个故事时，我不禁联想到《麦克白》：渴望王位的男人，逃往国外的敌对贵族，这些回响似乎非常诡异，也许它们是刻意为之的。我的意思是，《麦克白》是在苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世成为英格兰国王詹姆斯一世时写的。所以也许其中带有一种淡淡的皮影戏般的暗示吧？我不知道。
Certainly, Bothwell's wheeze in getting Morton to sign this bond doesn't work out because only two days after they've had their meeting in the pub, the inevitable happens. Morton goes back on his word. And this is, I mean, it's not a straw in the wind. It's a tree trunk in a howling gale. Because wherever Morton leads, others tend to follow. And the other thing, of course, that Bothwell knows about Morton is that those who oppose him
当然，博斯韦尔通过让莫顿签署这份契约来耍的花招并没有奏效，因为在他们开会后的短短两天内，不可避免的事情就发生了。莫顿反悔了。这——我的意思是，这不仅仅是风中芦苇，简直是狂风中的一棵大树。因为莫顿走到哪里，其他人往往就会跟到哪里。博斯韦尔对莫顿了解的另一件事是，那些反对他的人
tend to end up dead. So this is very, very alarming news. And I think it concentrates his mind because he now has a choice. He can either step back, give up his ambitions, and perhaps thereby make himself more vulnerable to those people who've already decided he needs to be removed, or he can go for broke. He can physically seize control of Mary, which, in a effect is to stage a coup. And what about Mary in all this? Because obviously there's this sort of sense of gathering tension, you know, things are moving towards a crisis, towards a resolution.
往往最终都会丧命。所以这是一个非常非常令人担忧的消息，我认为这集中了他的思想，因为他现在面临选择。他要么退一步，放弃野心，从而让自己更容易受到那些已经决定必须除掉他的人的攻击；要么就孤注一掷。他可以在肉体上控制玛丽，这实际上就是发动一场政变。在这场风波中的玛丽又是怎样的呢？因为显然有一种山雨欲来的紧张感，你知道的，事情正朝着危机和解决的方向发展。
Is she aware of this, do you think? Do you think she feels the walls closing in on her? Yes, I think so. And I think the measure of that is that on the 21st of April, she raised to sterling where she placed her son for safekeeping the previous autumn. And I think Mary has always realized that to control her son is to control the future. Yeah. So the fact that she now wants to go and get him and physically have him is a measure probably of how insecure she's feeling and how nervous. So she goes to Sterling and she tells the captain of the castle what she wants to do. And to her horror and consternation, the captain refuses her permission to remove James. And the reason for this, Guy explains it, a moderate politician with his finger on the pulse of the lords, he knew they would rebel if Bothwell got his hands on the air to the throne. That's the jeopardy for Mary,
你认为她意识到了这一点吗？你觉得她感觉到四面楚歌了吗？是的，我想是的。衡量这一点的标准是，在4月21日，她赶往斯特灵，去年秋天她曾将儿子安置在那里以确保安全。玛丽一直意识到，控制她的儿子就是控制未来。所以，她现在想要去接他并实际拥有他，大概能衡量出她感到多么缺乏安全感和紧张。因此她去了斯特灵，并告诉城堡队长她想做什么。令她惊恐和愕然的是，队长拒绝了她带走詹姆斯的许可。盖伊解释了其中的原因：一个对领主们的脉搏了如指掌的温和派政治家，他知道如果博斯韦尔染指王位继承人，他们就会叛乱。这就是玛丽面临的危机，
that it's now assumed even by her own placement that if she has possession of James, Bothwell will get possession of James. So he allows Mary in to see James, but only with female attendance. Mary spends two days with James, she kisses him goodbye, rides off, and that is the last time that she ever sees him. I mean, that's, yeah, it's very sad, isn't it? So then she goes to her birthplace. Linlithgow. And from there, the next day, she heads off to Holyrood, but she never, ever gets there. So what happens? So she's riding over a bridge that crosses a river outside Edinburgh when suddenly there comes the pounding of horse hooves. And she looks round and there is
现在甚至连她自己安插的人都认为，如果玛丽拥有詹姆斯，博斯韦尔就会掌控詹姆斯。因此，他允许玛丽进去见詹姆斯，但只能有女性随从陪伴。玛丽和詹姆斯度过了两天，她吻了他并告别，骑马离去，那是她最后一次见到他。我的意思是，这——是的，非常令人难过，对吧？然后她去了她的出生地——林利思哥（Linlithgow）。从那里，第二天，她动身前往荷里路德（Holyrood），但她再也没有到达那里。那么发生了什么？她正骑马穿过爱丁堡郊外的一座河流桥梁时，突然传来了急促的马蹄声。她环顾四周，只见
Bothwell at the head of some 800 horsemen. And he rides up to her and he seizes her horse's bridle. And he then abducts her to Dunbar, which is his great stronghold. And the news of this causes a consternation across Scotland. And three days later, in Stirling, where the young Prince James is, a consortium of nobles led by Morton, Assemble and another covenant, Dominic. They love it in Scotland. The Scots love a covenant. And this time they call themselves the Confederate Lords.
博斯韦尔率领着大约800名骑兵。他骑马上前，抓住了她马的缰绳。然后他将她劫持到他的主要据点邓巴（Dunbar）。这个消息在整个苏格兰引起了轩然大波。三天后，在小王子詹姆斯所在的斯特灵，以莫顿为首的一群贵族聚集在一起，又搞了一份契约。苏格兰人太爱这个了。苏格兰人喜欢契约。这一次他们自称为同盟领主（Confederate Lords），
and they pledged themselves to freeing the queen from her captivity. Meanwhile, the day before, Bothwell has appeared from out of the castle at Dunbar. He's ridden to Edinburgh, and there he has gone to his wife and strong-armed her into agreeing to a divorce, which is duly granted on the 3rd of May. And then three days after that, on the 6th of May, so 12 days after her abduction, Mary re-emerges from Dunbar and she's riding at the side of Bothwell along the road to Edinburgh and they enter the city and crowds meet them but they are sullen. They don't cheer. They don't shout out God save your majesty to Mary. And the mood of the capital remains sullen. One week later on the 12th of May,
他们发誓要将女王从囚禁中解救出来。与此同时，就在前一天，博斯韦尔从邓巴城堡现身。他骑马前往爱丁堡，找到了他的妻子，并用强硬手段迫使她同意离婚，离婚于5月3日正式批准。三天后的5月6日，即她被劫持12天后，玛丽从邓巴再次露面，她与博斯韦尔并肩骑马沿着通往爱丁堡的道路前进，他们进入了城市，人群迎面而来，但他们神情阴沉。他们没有欢呼。他们没有对玛丽高喊“愿上帝保佑陛下”。首都的气氛依然阴沉。一周后的5月12日，
Mary formally pardons Bothwell for his abduction of her and then she creates him the Duke of Orkney as she had previously elevated Darnley to a dukedom. This is a signal that she wants to marry a commoner. You know, she can only marry a duke. And the wedding to the new duke happens on the 15th of May in Holyrood. And Mary enters the palace's great hall for the wedding ceremony, dressed in a flowing black gown, the colour of mourning for Darnley.
玛丽正式赦免了博斯韦尔劫持她的罪行，并封他为奥克尼公爵（Duke of Orkney），正如她先前将达利擢升为公爵一样。这是一个信号，表明她想嫁给一个平民。（你知道的，她只能嫁给公爵。）与新公爵的婚礼于5月15日在荷里路德宫举行。玛丽身穿一件飘逸的黑色长裙——为达利服丧的颜色——走进了宫殿的大厅参加婚礼仪式。
And again, I mean, we mentioned Macbeth. This is very Hamlet, the sense. of the funeral baked meats, coldly furnishing forth the wedding table. And, you know, as in Hamlet where Gertrude's overregey marriage to Claudius is, you know, it doesn't go down well with Hamlet. Mary's marriage to Bothwell does not go down well with the people of Edinburgh. And the very evening of the wedding, a new placard is nailed to the gates of Holyrood. And it reads, as the common people say,
同样，我的意思是——我们提到了《麦克白》——这非常像《哈姆雷特》的感觉：丧仪余下的冷炙，恰好做了婚礼的酒席。就像在哈姆雷特中，格特鲁德（Gertrude）与克劳迪斯（Claudius）那场过于仓促的婚姻让哈姆雷特无法接受一样，玛丽与博斯韦尔的婚姻也同样无法被爱丁堡人民接受。就在婚礼当晚，一张崭新的海报被钉在了荷里路德的城门上。上面写着，正如普通百姓所说：
only harlots Mary in May So here's a question for you When they were in Dunbar In that great castle What had happened there Between Bothwell and Mary Because her biographers
只有娼妓才在五月结婚。所以这里有个问题要问你：当他们在邓巴时，在那个宏伟的城堡里，到底发生了什么？在博斯韦尔和玛丽之间，因为她的传记作家们
Have spilled a lot of ink On debating this, haven't they? So alongside the murder of Darnley This is the great debating point In the life of Mary Queen of Scots Because that accusation That she's a harlot that she's prostituted herself to Bothwell
为争论这一点泼了大量墨水，不是吗？除了谋杀达利之外，这是苏格兰女王玛丽一生中最大的争议点，因为“她是个娼妓、她把自己出卖给博斯韦尔”这种指控
is incredibly damaging and it massively informs initial interpretations of her abduction. So contemporary writes, she was minded to cause Bothwell to ravish her to the end that she made the sooner end his marriage which she promised before she caused the murder of her husband. So in other words,
极具破坏力，并且极大地影响了人们对她被劫持事件的最初解读。因此同时代的记录者写道：“她本意是让博斯韦尔强暴她，以便早日结束这段婚姻，这在她策划谋杀丈夫之前就答应过。”换句话说，
the whole thing is a setup that Mary was fully expecting Bothwell to come and seize her. This is definitely not true. Really? Just as Mary had not been ignorant of Darnley's murder, she had very clearly been startled, outraged, horrified by her abduction. So again, to quote John Guy, she was most definitely abducted against her will. But this in turn leads to a further question, which I think it is unanswerable for obvious reasons, but we'll, you know, say what I think. So the question is, was she? she then raped? Did Bothwell rape her in Dunbar? And it seems to me that the evidence for this is pretty solid. So we have someone who went with her, who rode with her to Dunbar, who accompanied
这一切都是个局，玛丽完全预料到博斯韦尔会来抓她。这绝对不是真的。真的吗？正如玛丽并非对达利被谋杀一无所知一样，她对自己的被劫持显然也感到震惊、愤怒和惊恐。再次引用约翰·盖伊（John Guy）的话：“她绝对是在违背意愿的情况下被劫持的。”但这反过来又引出了另一个问题，我认为由于显而易见的原因这是无法回答的，但我还是会说出我的想法。所以问题是：她当时被强暴了吗？博斯韦尔在邓巴强暴了她吗？在我看来，支持这一说法的证据相当确凿。有一个和她一起去的人，和她一起骑马去邓巴并陪伴她的人，名叫詹姆斯·梅尔维尔（James Melville），他是一位外交官，一直以来都是她最信任的助手之一。他写道：“女王不得不嫁给他，即博斯韦尔，鉴于他强暴了她并在她不情愿的情况下与她同房。”哦，好吧，那真是相当……但他说他在场吗？他当时在邓巴，他为什么要编造这个？他为什么要编造这个，确实如此。玛丽自己的评论——我的意思是，这有点痛苦、可怜。她写道：“虽然我们发现他的做法粗鲁，但他的言辞和回答还算温和。”所以，例如，约翰·盖伊将此解读为：博斯韦尔的追求方式比较粗暴，
her, is a guy called James Melville, who's a diplomat, who'd always been one of her most trusted aids. And he wrote, the queen could not but marry him, i.e. Bothwell, seeing he had ravished her and laid with her against her will. Oh, well, that is pretty. But did he say he was there? he was in Dunbar, why would he make it up? Why would he make it up, exactly? And Mary's own comment, I mean, it's kind of painful, pathetic. She wrote, albeit we found his doings rude, yet were his words and answers gentle. So John Guy, for instance, interprets that as meaning that Bothwell had pressed his suit roughly,
玛丽花了整整两天时间才被说服，这就是为什么博斯韦尔随后骑马回爱丁堡去跟妻子离婚的原因，并没有发生实质上的强暴。这只是一种比较粗鲁的求爱方式，如果你愿意这么认为的话。是的。我的意思是，这似乎——梅尔维尔所写的内容与玛丽本人所写的内容汇合在一起，在我看来指向了一个更加阴险的解释。我认为玛丽在说“他的做法粗鲁，他的言辞和回答温和”时，
and it had taken Mary two days to be persuaded, and that was why Bothwell had then ridden off to Edinburgh to divorce his wife. and that there had been no physical rape. It had just been a kind of rough wooing, if you like. Yeah. I mean, that doesn't seem, the confluence of what Melville writes and what Mary herself writes seems to me to point to a much more sinister explanation. And I think that what Mary is saying when she says, you know, that his doings were rude, his words and answers gentle,
几乎就像她知道自己现在必须嫁给他，并且她正试图说服自己，博斯韦尔仍然是她一直认为的那种骑士精神的典范，尽管她现在知道他并不是——他已经向她露出了真面目——而且我认为她根本没有说服自己相信这一点，
it's almost as though she knows that she now has to marry him. and she's trying to convince herself that Bothwell is still the model of chivalry that she'd always thought him to be even though she now knows that he isn't that he's revealed to her his true colours and I don't think she convinces herself about that at all
因为当她被看到离开邓巴，以及在她抵达爱丁堡后的几天乃至几周里，更不用说在她的婚礼上，她给人的印象依然是那种痛苦、破碎、被打败的模样。宫廷臣僚们说博斯韦尔既嫉妒又多疑，并执意要别人服从他。当然，对玛丽来说最悲惨的是，这跟达利一模一样。但你在博斯韦尔身上看到的——甚至比在达利身上更甚，这些关于达利的传言也曾流传过——是博斯韦尔私下里是一个
because when she is seen coming out of Dunbar and in the days and weeks that follow her arrival in Edinburgh and still more her wedding she seems to observe us to be kind of miserable, broken, defeated and courtiers say of Bothwell that he is jealous and suspicious and thinks to be obeyed. And of course, the miserable thing for Mary is that that's exactly like Darnley had been. But what you get with Bothwell, even more than with Darnley, and these stories were also told of Darnley, is that Bothwell in private is
有躯体虐待倾向的人。又是一部莎士比亚戏剧，这就像理查三世迎娶安妮·内维尔（Anne Neville）。是的。我的意思是，我认为这就是苏格兰女王玛丽的悲剧之所以能引起如此深刻共鸣的原因之一，因为它带有莎士比亚悲剧的色彩。它确实具备那种特质。是的，因为你在描述中，在笔记中指出，宫廷试图表现出一派欢乐和快活的景象，就好像一切如常。但有一种感觉，许多本该在那里的人并不在那里。是的。而且确实有一种像《麦克白》或《哈姆雷特》之类剧作中宫廷的感觉。
physically abusive. So another Shakespeare play, it's like Rich the third marrying Anne Neville. Yeah. I mean, I think this is one of the reasons why the tragedy of Mary Queen of Scots resonate so profoundly is that it is reminiscent of Shakespearean tragedy. It does have that kind of quality to it. Yeah, because you're describing, in your notes you point out that the court, they try to put on the appearance of jollity and gaiety as though it's business as usual. But there's a sort of sense that a lot of people who should be there are not there. Yeah. And there's a, you know, it does feel like the court in Macbeth or in Hamlet or something.
虽说达利的鬼魂没有出现，但是的，它确实很像《麦克白》中所有泰恩（Thane）领主纷纷逃亡时的宫廷。在玛丽的案例中，最残酷的打击来自梅特兰。梅特兰与博斯韦尔大吵了一架后，气冲冲地走了。当然，梅特兰娶了四玛丽（Four Marys）之一——高贵玛丽（Posh Mary），她一直以来都是与苏格兰女王玛丽最亲近的人，所以她也一起走了。因此玛丽对此感到心碎，泪如泉涌。梅特兰和高贵玛丽离开了，他们离开荷里路德宫，加入了同盟领主（Confederate Lords）。此时同盟领主的人数已经达到30人，很明显，这将是一场你死我活的战斗，而这场战斗玛丽已经处於即将失败的边缘。因此，到了6月初，莫顿和同盟领主已经开始逼近爱丁堡。玛丽不得不逃跑。她逃跑的速度如此之快，以至于来不及带上任何衣服、鞋子，也没有带任何金线刺绣的吊袜带。因此，
Well, so it's not to say the ghost of Darnley appears. So, but yeah, it is like the court of Macbeth when all the Thanes are fleeing. Yeah. And in Mary's case, the cruelest blow comes when Maitland, who's had a massive row with Bothwell, he storms off. And of course, Maitland is married to one of the four Mary. posh mary who's the one who'd always been closest to mary queen of scots and so she goes as well and so mary's devastated by this left in floods of tears and maitland and posh mary go off they leave hollyrood they join the confederate lords who by now number 30 and it's clear that there is going to be a fight to the death and it's a fight that mary is already on the verge of losing so by early june morton and the confederate lords are already closing in on Edinburgh. And Mary has to run away. And she does this in such high speed that she can't get any of her clothes together, none of her shoes, none of her gold-embroidered garters. So
场面绝对是一片混乱。她只能带走最基本的东西：一个银盆、一个银水壶、一个装着她文件的首饰盒和许多发夹。这其中非常强调她的个人修饰，也就是梳理头发。所以她确实带了文件，但除此之外，一切都是为了确保她那红褐色的发丝看起来处于最佳状态。接着是一个绝对致命的打击，因为就在她离开爱丁堡后，一直由博斯韦尔的一个追随者控制的爱丁堡城堡，立刻倒戈投奔了同盟领主。这显然是一个信号，表明他已经决定了谁胜谁负。
absolute scenes. And all she can take are the barest essential. So a silver basin, a silver kettle, a small cabinet containing her papers and lots of hair pins. And there's very much an emphasis there on her toilet. So the dressing of her hair. So she does take her papers, but otherwise everything is needed to make sure that her auburn tresses are looking their best. And then there's an absolute killer blow, because the moment she's left Edinburgh, Edinburgh Castle, which has been under the rule of one of Bothwell's followers, he immediately switches aside and goes over to the Confederate Lords. So this is a sign that clearly, you know, he's decided who's winning and who's losing.
所以同盟领主现在占领了爱丁堡，并向一座名为博思韦克（Borthwick）的城堡推进，玛丽就在那里避难。他们将城堡包围。6月11日夜里，玛丽女扮男装，从包围圈中溜了出去，骑马赶去
So the Confederate Lords have now taken Edinburgh and they advance on a castle called Borthwick, which is where Mary has taken refuge. and they put it under siege and on the night of the 11th of June Mary dresses up as a man she slips out through the besieging lines and she rides her way
与博斯韦尔会合。这让人不幸地回想起当年在法国时，她和四玛丽曾打扮成男孩、伪装自己的那些恶作剧般的时光；而现在，她乔装打扮是为了逃避那些想要推翻她的人，真是悲惨。但她确实能够与博斯韦尔重新会合，对吧？博斯韦尔当时正在边境招募军队。他们确实组建了一支像样的军队。因此到了6月中旬，他们希望重新夺回爱丁堡，并让她复位。
to join with Bothwell and there's a kind of unhappy memory there of those times in France when she and the four Marys had dressed up as boys and disguised themselves all those kind of larks and now she's disguising herself
此时的她一点也不像个男人。你在笔记中形容她看起来非常具有“新浪漫主义”风格。是的，我说过，她没有带上自己最好的衣服，所以她穿着某种红色的衬裙和天鹅绒帽子，以及各种零散的衣物。她看起来——我的意思是，她看起来确实挺有魅力的，但绝对不像一个时髦的法国女王。因此，她和博斯韦尔率领军队向爱丁堡进发，到达了马瑟堡（Musselbrough）以南的地方。
to escape people who want, you know, who want to topple her, so miserable. But she is able to rejoin Bothwell, isn't she? So Bothwell's been raising troops in the borders. And they actually do get a decent army. So by the middle of June, they're hoping to recapture Edinburgh. And they can set her.
横亘在他们面前的是卡伯里山（Carbury Hill）。在这里，他们迎面撞上了同盟领主的军队。同盟领主打着一面巨大的旗帜，考虑到莫顿正是举旗的领主之一，这面旗帜虚伪至极。旗帜上绘有达利那具惨遭谋杀的尸体。在达利旁边，绣着一个跪地祈祷的幼童，
And at this point, she's not looking like a man at all. You describe her in your notes as looking very new romantic. Yeah, so I said, you know, she hasn't taken her best clothes. So she's wearing kind of red petticoat and a velvet hat. and kind of various items of clothing. And she looks, I mean, she looks kind of quite glamorous, but not like a, not like a fashionable French queen, certainly. And so she and Bothwell, at the head of their army, they're marching on Edinburgh, and they reach just south of Musselbrough.
这面旗帜上的标语是：“主啊，请审判并为我的事业复仇。”再强调一下，我的意思是，这是莫顿的旗帜。对，太荒谬了。所以对玛丽来说，此时的情况看起来相当严峻。你指出威廉·塞西尔在伦敦——
And their head of them is Carbury Hill. And here they run into the army of the Confederate Lords. and the Confederate lords have a massive banner, which couldn't be more hypocritical, bearing in mind that Morton is one of the lords who is carrying it. This banner is decorated with the poor murdered body of Darnley. And next to Darnley, there is a young child has been embroidered who is shown praying on his knees. the slogan on this banner judge and revenge my cause
伊丽莎白一世的第一大臣曾把苏格兰政治比作某种泥潭或沼泽，当时有一种感觉，她已经被淹没在没顶之灾中，因为卡伯里山并没有真正发生战斗，只是一场在煎熬酷热中的墨西哥式僵局。
oh lord and just to reiterate I mean this is Morton's banner yeah bonkers so things are looking pretty bleak for Mary at this point you point out that William Cecil had in London
实际上很明显，势头掌握在同盟领主手中，而不是玛丽和博斯韦尔手中，因为她的军队开始逃亡，他们只是三三两两地溜进石南丛或其他什么地方。这很有趣，因为其中带有一种骑士精神的维度，
Elizabeth I first minister had talked about Scottish politics being a kind of quagmire or bog or something and there's a sense at this point that she's been pulled down beneath her depths because there is no battle actually at Carbury Hill there's just this sort of Mexican standoff in punishing punishing heat
因为有各种尝试去安排博斯韦尔与莫顿进行单打独斗，博斯韦尔想和莫顿打。但莫顿相当年迈，已经很久没有打过仗了，所以他不想这么做。人们曾多次尝试寻找一个旗鼓相当的对手。但玛丽最终介入并说：“不，我们不这么做。”因此，并没有出现一场伟大的亚瑟王式的决斗，情况恰恰相反，她的军队只是自行溃散了。
and actually it's clear that the momentum lies with the Confederate Lords and not with Mary and Bothwell because her troops begin to desert and they were just to sort of slink away into the heather or whatever it is. I mean it's interesting because there's there is a kind of a chivalric dimension to it
没有发生战斗。最终，玛丽被迫与同盟领主谈判。她的条件是：应该允许博斯韦尔骑马离去，而她将置于同盟领主的保护之下。她之所以这么做，一部分原因是因为她此时知道自己怀上了他的孩子。所以她会希望孩子的父亲依然活跃在现场。而且她也知道，只要博斯韦尔恢复自由，
because there are kind of various attempts to fix up single combat between Bothwell who wants to fight with Morty But Morton's kind of pretty elderly, hasn't fought in a battle for ages, so he doesn't want to do that. And there's various attempts to find a kind of rival champion. But Mary, in the end, steps in and says, no, we're not going to do this. And so rather than a kind of great Arthurian combat, it's the opposite. Her troops just melt away.
就总还存在着一种希望，即他或许能够召集军队前来救援，将她从同盟领主为她计划的命运中拯救出来。于是他们拥抱了。博斯韦尔随即上马，调转马头，扬长而去，这对夫妻从此再也未曾相见。那么玛丽呢？她后来怎么样了？她被从卡伯里山带到了爱丁堡，这很像路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特试图逃跑失败后的情形。她由根本不尊重她的士兵看守着。玛丽对受到这样的对待感到震惊。
There is no battle. And in the end, Mary is forced to negotiate with the Confederate Lords. And her terms are, Bothwell should be allowed to ride away. and she will come under the protection of the Confederate Lords. And the reason that she does this, I think partly because she is, she knows by now that she's pregnant by him. So she would want the father of her child, you know, still to be active and on the scene. And also she knows that while Bothwell is at liberty,
我的意思是，我想她根本不知道自己在敌人当中变得如此不受欢迎。她被带到爱丁堡。她不被允许去荷里路德宫，而是被安置在一栋私人住宅里。从那扇窗户探出身子时，她看到梅特兰从下方走过，便大声呼喊他。而梅特兰非常刻意地没有抬头。随后，她从爱丁堡被带过福斯湾（Firth of Forth）前往法夫（Fife）。一旦进入法夫，她就被向北带到
there is always the hope that he might be able to raise an army and come to her rescue and save her from whatever fate the Confederate Lords have. in plan for her. So they do embrace. Bothwell then gets onto his horse, turns it round, gallops away, and husband and wife will never see each other again. So Mary, what happens to her? Well, she is taken from Carbury Hill to Edinburgh and it's quite like the return of Louis the 16th and Marianne Twennett after they'd attempted their escape. So she's guarded by soldiers who show her no respect at all. Mary is absolutely stunned to be treated like this.
湖文城堡（Loch Leven）。这是一处位于湖心岛屿上、极难接近的据点。人们可能还记得，早在第一集刚开始时，她曾被带到一座修道院以逃避粗鲁的求爱，而现在，她又回到了湖中的一座岛上，
I mean, I think she had no idea how unpopular she's become with her enemies. She's taken to Edinburgh. She's not allowed to go to Holyrood. She's put in a kind of a private house. And from that window, she leans out and she sees Maitland passing and she calls out to him. And Maitland very pointedly does not look up. And then from Edinburgh, she is taken across the Firth of Fourth to Fife. and once in Fife she is taken northwards
但这一次，她是个囚徒。哦天哪！她的看守们并不是她的粉丝，对吧？威廉·道格拉斯爵士（Sir William Douglas）是莫顿家族的一员，也是她老死敌莫雷伯爵同母异父的兄弟。所以这不是什么好消息。是的，威廉·道格拉斯，也就是湖文的领主，他的母亲曾是詹姆斯五世的情妇之一，这位老母亲至今仍在世，她一直痛恨玛丽，并且显然觉得自己的儿子才应该是国王。
up to the castle of Loch Levin which is a very inaccessible stronghold on an island in the middle of a lock and people may remember right back in the beginning of episode one she got taken to a monastery to escape the rough wooing and now here she is she's back on an island
对。所以她是一个充满恶意的存在，一点也不喜欢玛丽。此外还有一个非常阴险的人物，名叫林赛勋爵（Lord Lindsay），他是同盟领主之一，与莫顿非常亲近（这绝不是什么好兆头），并且曾是里乔的凶手之一。所以对玛丽来说，身边有这样的人一点也不有趣。她确实有玛丽·西顿（Mary Seton）陪伴，也就是那个负责梳妆的高贵玛丽。
in a lock but this time she's a prisoner oh dear so her guardians they're not big fans of hers are they Sir William Douglas he's a member of the kind of Morton clan and the half-brother of her old arch-enemy
她去了，所以这是个好消息，因为显然玛丽有她的热水和发夹之类的小物件，至少她能保持良好的外表。而且她也被允许带几个仆人。但实际上，她是个阶下囚，而且感到彻底的、彻头彻尾的痛苦。随后又迎来了两次沉重的打击。首先，她流产了，失去了腹中的双胞胎，两个孩子都没了。接着不久之后的7月24日，阴险的林赛勋爵带着一整团同盟领主代表团来到了岛上。林赛向玛丽出示了三份文件。第一份是立她儿子詹姆斯为王的退位声明；第二份对玛丽来说极其痛苦，是任命莫雷为詹姆斯的摄政；第三份是，在莫雷从法国返回接任之前，由莫顿担任摄政。显然，玛丽是绝不会签署这些文件的。
the Earl of Moray. So that's not good news. Yeah, so William Douglas, who's the laird of Loughley and his mother had been one of James V's mistresses and this mother is still alive and she had always detested Mary and clearly felt that her boy should be king.
莫雷伯爵。所以这并不是好消息。是的，威廉·道格拉斯是洛克利的领主，他的母亲曾是詹姆斯五世的情妇之一，这位母亲至今仍然在世，她一直极其厌恶玛丽，显然认为她的儿子才应该当国王。
Right. So she's a very malevolent presence, not keen on Mary at all. And also there's a very sinister figure called Lord Lindsay, who's a Confederate at Lord who, very close to Morton, never a good sign, and had been one of Rizio's killers. So he's not a fun person for Mary to have around either. She does have Mary Seton, so Fashion Mary, the hairdresser.
没错。所以她是一个充满恶意的存在，对玛丽一点也不友好。此外还有一个非常险恶的人物叫林赛勋爵，他是叛乱贵族的一员，与莫顿非常亲近，这绝不是什么好兆头，而且他还是里齐奥的凶手之一。所以对玛丽来说，身边有这样一个人也绝不好受。不过她确实留下了玛丽·西顿，也就是时尚玛丽、那个发型师。
She's gone and so this is good news because obviously Mary has got her hot water and her pins and things, so at least she can look good. And also she's allowed a few servants. But effectively, she is a prisoner and she's utterly, utterly miserable. And then two further body blows come. First, she has a miscarriage and she loses what turned out to be twins. So two babies are lost. And then shortly after that, on the 24th of July, the very sinister Lord Lindsay arrives on the island. He's got a whole delegation of Confederate lords with him. And Lindsay presents Mary with three documents. The first of these is a declaration of abdication in favor of her son, James. The second, very painful for Mary is the appointment of Moray as regent for James. And the third is that while Moray is coming back from France to take up his post, Morton should serve as regent. Obviously, Mary is not going to sign these.
她留下了，这算是个好消息，因为显然玛丽需要热水、别针之类的东西，至少这样她能保持得体。而且她也被允许留用几个仆人。但实际上，她是一个囚犯，而且极其极其痛苦。接着，两个更沉重的打击接踵而至。首先，她流产了，失去了腹中的双胞胎。两个孩子就这样夭折了。紧接着在7月24日，那个极其险恶的林赛勋爵登上了小岛。他带着一整支叛乱贵族代表团。林赛向玛丽出示了三份文件。第一份是拥立她儿子詹姆斯即位的退位声明；第二份对玛丽而言极为痛苦，是任命莫雷担任詹姆斯的摄政；第三份是规定在莫雷从法国回来就职期间，由莫顿担任摄政。显然，玛丽是绝不会签署这些文件的。
She says, no, there's no way I'm going to do this. Lindsay then starts to menace her with the prospect of more restrictive prisons, then of being drowned in the the lock, and then finally he threatens to cut her throat. And bear in mind that Mary has seen Lindsay in action getting rid of Rizio. And so at this point, she, in floods of tears, agrees that she will sign the documents. But she promises as she does so, when God shall set me at liberty again, I shall not abide these, for it is done against my will. But, you know, these are empty words, really, because she has now signed her abdication. And she is no longer Queen of Scots.
她说，不，我绝不可能这么做。林赛随后开始威胁她，称要把她关进戒备更森严的监狱，接着威胁要把她淹死在护城河里，最后甚至威胁要割断她的喉咙。请记住，玛丽曾亲眼目睹林赛为了除掉里奇奥而采取的行动。因此在这一刻，她泪流满面，同意签署文件。但她在签署时承诺，当上帝让我重获自由时，我绝不遵守这些，因为这是违背我的意愿的。但你知道，这些其实都是空洞的言辞，因为她现在已经签署了退位诏书，她不再是苏格兰女王了。
What a bombshell. We'll find out what happens to Mary after the break. We read and almost broken, with the frequent uproars and rebellions raised against us since we return to Scotland. So Mary Queen of Scott, she hasn't lost her French accent, which is, that's some consolation, I suppose.
真是个重磅炸弹。我们将在中场休息后揭晓玛丽后来的遭遇。我们宣读着，由于我们返回苏格兰以来不断遭受叛乱和暴动的打击，几乎心力交瘁。所以苏格兰女王玛丽，她还没有丢掉她那口法国腔，我想这多少算是一点安慰吧。
Anyway, that's a briefing note. She dictated that to her secretary, and it was taken by her ambassador to Elizabeth I. And it is describing her circumstances, her mood, after the collapse of her regime and the end of her queenship following her marriage to the Earl of Bothwell. Of course, the great irony is Elizabeth, the person to whom she addresses that note, effectively.
总之，这是一份简报。这是她口述给秘书的，然后由她的驻伊丽莎白一世大使送出。信中描述了她在政权崩溃、结束女王生涯（因与博斯韦尔伯爵结婚）后的处境和心情。当然，莫大的讽刺在于，伊丽莎白正是她写信的对象。
Elizabeth had said, look, you should identify Bothwell as the culprit and Donna's death. You should execute him, punish him, make an example of him. rid yourself of this. Not only does she not do that, she actually marries him. Now the bonkers thing is that Mary still thinks at this point that Elizabeth will support her. And remember they've never met. And at different moments, she's A, wanted to be Elizabeth's heir, but she's also set herself up as a rival to Elizabeth. But she thinks Elizabeth will be the, you know, the white knight who will somehow save her. And is that realistic? Tom, I don't think it is
伊丽莎白曾说，听着，你应该把博斯韦尔视为谋杀达恩利的罪魁祸首。你应该处决他，惩罚他，杀一儆百，摆脱这个人。她不仅没有这样做，反而真的嫁给了他。现在最疯狂的是，玛丽在这个时候依然认为伊丽莎白会支持她。记住，她们从未谋面。在不同的时期，她一方面想成为伊丽莎白的继承人，另一方面又把自己树立为伊丽莎白的竞争对手。但她认为伊丽莎白会成为那种骑士，某种程度上会拯救她。这现实吗？汤姆，我觉得一点也不
realistic. Well, actually, it is quite realistic because obviously Elizabeth disapproves of Mary marrying unsuitable men. But the thing she really disapproves of is rebellion against an anointed monarch. And she, when the news of Mary's deposition is brought to her, she is absolutely appalled. And all the more so, because of the definite whiff of what Elizabeth sees as unsound heretical theology that surrounds it. So listeners may remember John Knox, the great shepherd of the Scottish Reformation, that he had met Mary and he had lectured her, telling Mary that unworthy monarchs can legitimately be toppled and imprisoned, that this is the will of God.
现实。好吧，其实这相当现实，因为很明显伊丽莎白不赞成玛丽嫁给不合适的男人。但她真正不赞成的是对受膏君主的叛乱。当玛丽被废黜的消息传到她耳中时，她感到极其震惊。更让她震惊的是，其中明显弥漫着伊丽莎白所认为的不健全的异端神学气息。因此听众可能还记得约翰·诺克斯，苏格兰宗教改革的伟大领袖，他曾与玛丽会面并训诫过她，告诉玛丽不合格的君主可以被合法的推翻并监禁，这就是上帝的旨意。
And this is a perspective that quite a lot of the kind of the hotter Protestants in England also share. And there is therefore no way that Elizabeth is likely to back Mary's deposition because she sees it exactly as Mary sees it as being an expression of kind of incipient republicanism, this Protestant idea that the godly have a right to depose an unworthy monarch. Neither Elizabeth nor Mary won't have anything to do with it. And I think that in her depth of her misery, following her miscarriage, following her. her forced abdication, this is the straw that Mary clings to. And it helps her to get back some of her spirits. It helps to redeem her from the misery that she's been plunged into. It helps her to recover from her kind of her sickness, her sense of exhaustion, her despair.
这也是英国许多比较激进的新教徒所持有的观点。因此，伊丽莎白绝不可能支持玛丽被废黜，因为她和玛丽的看法一样，认为这是初露端倪的共和主义的表达，是一种认为虔诚者有权废黜不合格君主的新教思想。伊丽莎白和玛丽都不会容忍这种事。我认为在经历流产和被迫退位之后，在极度的痛苦中，这是玛丽紧紧抓住的最后一根救命稻草。这帮她恢复了一些精神，帮她摆脱了陷入的悲惨境地，帮她从疾病、精疲力竭和绝望感中恢复过来。
And another thing that helps her to recover, I think, from being depressed, is she finds that she hasn't lost her power to charm and to fascinate. I think she's been very very, depressed by being cat-called in Edinburgh, but now she has male admirers in the castle, it turns out. So one of these is the dashing younger brother of Sir William Douglas, who is the brooding laird of Lockleven Castle. And this is a guy who's known as Pretty Geordie. Of course he is. George Douglas. And he falls madly in love with Mary Queen of Scots.
我认为另一个帮她从抑郁中恢复过来的原因是，她发现自己并没有失去施展魅力和迷倒他人的能力。我认为她在爱丁堡遭到嘘声时曾感到非常非常沮丧，但现在城堡里出现了一些爱慕她的男士。其中一位是威廉·道格拉斯爵士英勇的弟弟，威廉爵士是阴郁的洛克莱文城堡的领主。这个家伙被称为“英俊乔迪”。当然啦，他就是乔治·道格拉斯。他疯狂地爱上了苏格兰女王玛丽。
And in fact, he will stick with her for the rest of her life. And with pretty Geordie on her side, Mary is able to make two attempts to escape. The first of these doesn't work out. It's faintly ludicrous. It requires her dressing up as a washerwoman. So like... Like, Toad. Like Toad of Toad Hall trying to escape prison.
事实上，他将在余生中一直追随她。在英俊乔迪的支持下，玛丽得以两次尝试逃跑。第一次没有成功。这甚至有点滑稽。它需要她扮成洗衣妇。就像……就像蟾蜍。就像《柳林中的风声》里的蟾蜍试图逃狱一样。
So unlike Toad, Mary Queen of Scots doesn't succeed in escaping because her hands are very white and soft. And these are noticed. And so she gets apprehended. taken back to Lockleaven. But then a second attempt is much more successful because by this point she has wowed not only Pretty Geordie, but also Little Willie Douglas.
所以与蟾蜍不同，苏格兰女王玛丽并没有逃跑成功，因为她的双手非常白皙柔软。这些特征被注意到了。因此她被重新抓获，并被带回洛克莱文。但第二次尝试要成功得多，因为此时她不仅迷住了英俊乔迪，还迷住了小威利·道格拉斯。
Who's an even younger Douglas boy on the scene. And you think, oh God, it's so amazing. And so what he does, Little Willie Douglas goes around and he sabotages all the boats but one, which he then gives to Mary. And so she is able to be rowed across the lock and no one is able to pursue her. And so she gets away.
现场还有一个更年轻的道格拉斯男孩。你会想，哦天哪，这太神奇了。所以他所做的是，小威利·道格拉斯到处破坏了所有的船只，只留下一艘，然后他把这艘船交给了玛丽。于是她得以乘船穿过湖泊，没有人能够追赶她。就这样她逃掉了。
And so now she's free. Hooray. Amazing. So she's free. She's going to tell about the crown, presumably, like all Scotland lies at her feet, or does it? It doesn't, does it?
所以现在她自由了。万岁。太棒了。所以她自由了。她大概要宣称对王冠的所有权，仿佛整个苏格兰都匍匐在她的脚下，事实是这样吗？并不是，对吧？
No, it doesn't. I mean, it really should have done. Mary has all the advantages. She might be unpopular with certain segments of society in Edinburgh, but across the sweep of Scotland, she is seen as the rightful queen. And we've been talking about this throughout the series, how loyalty to the Scottish throne
不，并不是。我的意思是，本来确实应该如此。玛丽拥有所有的优势。她可能在爱丁堡的某些社会阶层中不受欢迎，但在整个苏格兰范围内，她被视为合法的女王。我们整个系列都在讨论，对苏格兰王位
to the Stuart family is very, very strong and Mary is in pole position to capitalise on this. And so sure enough, when she reappears, her Auburn locks flowing in the wind, thousands of men flock to her banner. And she goes to Hamilton, which is a town to the south of Glasgow, where there was very recently a by-election.
对斯图亚特家族的忠诚是多么多么强烈，而玛丽正处于利用这一优势的最佳位置。因此不出所料，当她重新出现，金红色的卷发在风中飘扬时，数千名男子涌向她的旗帜下。她前往汉密尔顿，那是格拉斯哥南部的一个城镇，那里不久前刚刚举行过补缺选举。
And there she sets up her court directly opposite Glasgow, which is where Morey is and Lennox and all her bitterest enemies. And actually, various congregant lords do leave Murray. They do go over to Mary. And so you'd think, oh, come on, this is it. This is your chance.
并在那里建立了她的宫廷，与格拉斯哥隔河相望，莫瑞、伦纳德和她所有最死硬的敌人就在那里。事实上，一些赞同她的贵族确实离开了莫瑞，投奔了玛丽。所以你会想，哦，拜托，就是这样。这是你的机会。
And sure enough, two weeks after her escape from Loch Leaven, Mary does meet with her enemies in battle at a place called Langside, a village outside Glasgow. She has a much larger army. She should have won. She doesn't. The battle lasts three quarters of an hour. That's enough for Mary's forces to be.
果不其然，在从洛克莱文逃脱两周后，玛丽在格拉斯哥郊外一个叫兰赛德的村庄与她的敌人们展开了战斗。她拥有大得多的军队。她本该赢的。但她没有。战斗持续了三刻钟。这足够让玛丽的军队
routed and so she turns tail and she flees in desperation southwards and first she goes to Dumfries and then she cuts across country travelling by night into the wilds of Galloway and it's the measure of how distraught she is how terrified of being captured that at this point she actually shaves off her hair her beloved Auburn hair to avoid being recognised and she recalled later just how awful an experience this escape into the wilds have been. I have had to sleep upon the ground and drink sour milk and eat oatmeal without bread and have been three nights like the owls.
溃败，于是她掉转马头，绝望地向南逃窜。她先是去了邓弗里斯，然后连夜穿过乡村，进入加洛韦的荒野。她当时是多么的心烦意乱，多么害怕被俘，以至于她竟然剃掉了自己的头发，她那心爱的金红色头发，以此来避免被认出来。她后来回忆起这次逃入荒野的经历是多么可怕。我不得不睡在地上，喝酸牛奶，吃没有面包的燕麦片，像猫头鹰一样过了三个晚上。
And now, you know, you talked in the very first episode about her sense of fun and that being one of her defining characteristics. But now she's pretty much lost all that completely, hasn't she? She's having to drink sour milk. Well, there's that, but also she's lost her child. She's probably been raped, lost her crown. She's been chased all over Scotland. She's crushed.
现在，你在第一集里谈到过她对快乐的追求，那是她的定义性特征之一。但现在她几乎完全失去了这一切，不是吗？她不得不喝酸牛奶。嗯，除了这些，她还失去了孩子。她可能被强奸了，失去了王位。她在整个苏格兰到处被追捕。她彻底崩溃了。
Yeah, completely demoralised. Lost her self-confidence. And so it's at that point that even though her followers are saying, come on, stay in Scotland, don't give up, don't give up. She says, no, I will go to England. I will throw myself on the mercy of Elizabeth I first and ask her to restore me to my throne. She does.
是的，完全士气低落。失去了自信。正因如此，尽管她的追随者们说，拜托，留在苏格兰，不要放弃，不要放弃。她说，不，我要去英国。我要把自己交托给伊丽莎白一世的仁慈，请求她恢复我的王位。她真的这么做了。
So on the 15th of May, she arrives at the abandoned abbey of Dunnard. Drainon, which is a mile away from the coast of the Solway Firth, the expanse of water that separates Galaway from Cumberland in England. And the next day she goes to, down to the beach, there's a fishing vessel has been sourced for her. She gets in it and she's rode across the Solway Firth to England and she will never again step foot on Scottish soil and she will never again no freedom because we've been talking about this escalating sequence of disastrous decisions that she makes. And her decision to go to England is the last and culminating disastrous decision because it is one that will lead directly to her date with the chopping
因此，在5月15日，她抵达了废弃的邓纳德修道院。德雷农，距离索尔韦湾海岸仅一英里，这片水域将加洛韦与英格兰的坎布里亚郡隔开。第二天她来到海滩，那里为她租好了一艘渔船。她坐了上去，被船桨载着穿过索尔韦湾进入英格兰，她将再也没有踏上苏格兰的土地，也再也不会品尝到自由的滋味，因为我们一直在讨论她所做出的一系列不断升级的灾难性决策。她前往英国的决定是最后也是最高潮的灾难性决定，因为这个决定将直接导致19年后她在福瑟林盖的断头台
block in Fotheringay 19 years later. So for the next 19 years years, she is going to be in England. And she never imagined that when she crossed the border. She thought she'd be back within weeks, months. She assumes, I think, that because Elizabeth is opposed to the deposition of anointed monarchs, therefore Elizabeth will back her. And I think also Mary has no comprehension of just how difficult a situation her arrival in England is for Elizabeth. she just hasn't computed it because for Elizabeth, the arrival of Mary in England is a nightmare because it obliges her to choose between giving support to an anointed queen, which is, you know, every fibre in her being is saying this is what she should do.
上丧生。因此在接下来的19年里，她都将在英格兰度过。当她越过边境时，她绝没有想到这一点。她以为自己几周、几个月内就能回去。我想她假设，由于伊丽莎白反对废黜受膏君主，因此伊丽莎白会支持她。而且我认为玛丽也没有意识到，她到达英国对伊丽莎白来说是多么艰难的处境。她根本没有计算过这一点，因为对伊丽莎白来说，玛丽抵达英国是一场噩梦，因为它迫使她在支持一位受膏女王（你知道，她内心的每一个纤维都在告诉她这正是她应该做的）之间做出选择。
And her utter horror are getting sucked into a civil war in Scotland because Elizabeth hates foreign entanglements. So two of her great principles are now in direct opposition with one another. And what adds to, I think, to her general mood of paralysis and indecision is the fact that Murray, who by now has come back from France and installed himself as the Regent of Scotland, he's actually doing a really good job. I mean, he's a much, much steadier hand on the tiller of the Scottish ship of state than Mary had ever provided. And of course, also, he's Protestant. So, you know, from Elizabeth's point of view, he's Protestant, he's calm, he's politically skillful, he's. not kind of running around Scotland, marrying unsuitable people and doing disastrous things. So I think very reluctantly, Elizabeth finds herself thinking, well, actually, maybe he's doing
以及她对被卷入苏格兰内战的极度恐惧，因为伊丽莎白讨厌外国纠葛。因此，她的两大核心原则现在直接对立了。我认为，导致她普遍陷入瘫痪和犹豫不决情绪的另一个因素是，莫瑞此时已经从法国返回，并自立为苏格兰摄政王，他其实做得非常好。我的意思是，他比玛丽以往任何时候都更能稳稳地把持苏格兰国家之船的舵。当然，他也是新教徒。所以，从伊丽莎白的观点来看，他是新教徒，他很冷静，政治上很娴熟，不是那种在苏格兰四处乱跑、嫁给不合适的人并做灾难性事情的人。所以我想伊丽莎白非常不情愿地发现自己想，好吧，其实也许他做得
a better job than the Anointed Queen would. But then again, you know, Mary is the Anointed Queen. So it's an absolute nightmare. And if there's one thing that Elizabeth is very good at weaponising, it's her complete sense of indecision. You know, when she's faced with things that she doesn't want to decide about. She just prevaricates. And often that turns out to be the best policy. And so that's what she does. Basically, she sits on her hands. And this is why she refuses to see Mary. And her chief minister, William Sessorheda, always hated Mary, as you've said many times in this series. And now, Mary, the Catholic, is out of Scotland, which he always wanted. And what is even better? She has delivered herself up as a gift to him because she's come to
比那位受膏女王要好。但话又说回来，你知道，玛丽是受膏女王。所以这绝对是一场噩梦。如果说伊丽莎白有什么非常擅长作为武器的东西，那就是她彻底的犹豫不决。你知道，当她面对不想做出决定的事情时，她只是敷衍塞责。通常这会被证明是最佳策略。所以她就是这么做的。基本上，她袖手旁观。这就是为什么她拒绝见玛丽。而她的首席大臣威廉·塞西尔一直都很讨厌玛丽，正如你在这个系列中多次说过的那样。现在，身为天主教徒的玛丽离开了苏格兰，这是他一直想要的。而更棒的是什么？她主动把自己当作礼物送给了他，因为她来到了
England. And again, Mary has no comprehension of the realities of the situation at the English court. So three days after she's arrived in England, she writes to Cecil and to quote her, I write to you above all others in my just quarrel at this time of trouble in the hope of obtaining the assistance of your good counsel. And as John Guy puts it, when Cecil read this letter, all he could do was laugh. I mean, the very idea that he would help Mary. Right. And so far from helping her, what he does is place her under effective detention in Bolton Castle, which is kind of, it's in the north of England, but it's a fair distance from the Scottish border. So Mary can't make a dash for the frontier. And then he writes to Murray and he asks for evidence against the captive queen. And what he wants evidence of is the fact that Mary was guilty of murdering Darnley. Because if that could, be found, then that cuts the Gordian not for Elizabeth, because she then is absolved of responsibility for helping Mary. And Murray, sure enough, manages to find some evidence.
英格兰。同样，玛丽对英国宫廷现实情况毫无理解。在她到达英国三天后，她写信给塞西尔，引用她的话：“在这个多事之秋，我为我正义的争端写信给你，超过所有人，希望能得到你好的辩护的协助。”正如约翰·盖伊所说，当塞西尔读到这封信时，他只能大笑。我的意思是，他会帮助玛丽的想法简直荒谬。对。不仅没有帮助她，他反而将她置于博尔顿城堡的有效拘禁之下，那里位于英格兰北部，但距离苏格兰边境有相当一段距离。因此玛丽无法冲向边境。然后他写信给莫瑞，索要针对这位被囚禁女王的证据。他想要得到的证据是玛丽犯有谋杀达恩利的罪行。因为如果能找到这些，就能为伊丽莎白斩断戈耳迪之结，因为这样她就可以免除帮助玛丽的责任。而莫瑞果然设法找到了一些证据。
And he sends Cecil a dossier, which is designed very explicitly to demonstrate that Mary had indeed been complicit in Darnley's murder and that therefore Elizabeth could legitimately wash her hands of her. And the allegations are that Mary had been sleeping. with Bothwell, pursuing an adulterous affair with him, before Darnley's murder, that Mary had conspired with Bothwell to murder Darnley, and that her abduction by Bothwell had actually been staged, that it had been completely faked, that there had been no rape, that Mary had an adulterous passion for Bothwell. Right.
他给塞西尔送去了一份卷宗，其目的非常明确，就是要证明玛丽确实参与了谋杀达恩利的阴谋，因此伊丽莎白可以合乎情理地与她划清界限。这些指控称，玛丽在达恩利被谋杀之前，一直与博斯韦尔同床共枕，与他保持着通奸关系，玛丽与博斯韦尔密谋谋杀达恩利，她被博斯韦尔绑架其实是一场精心策划的戏码，完全是伪造的，根本没有强奸，玛丽对博斯韦尔有着通奸般的热情。没错。
And the case for the prosecution is helped by two key factors. And the first of these is the fact that Bothwell himself is no longer on the scene to to what is being reported. So we last left him galloping away from Carbury Hill, leaving Mary forever. He doesn't hang around. He flees Scotland for Orkney, of which he's now the Earl. Then he goes to Shetland. And then he crosses the North Sea and ends up in Norway.
而起诉案情得到了两个关键因素的帮助。其中第一个因素是博斯韦尔本人已经不在现场来回应
There things go very badly for him. So to quote Wormald, who expresses it, I think, with undisguised relish. He fell foul of the kinsman of a former mistress, very improbable, was in imprisoned by Frederick, the king of Denmark and Norway, and died in 1578 in the fortress of Draggsholm, which I think is about 70 miles from Copenhagen, chained to a pillar and quite mad. Oh, right. John Guy has a different opinion on this.
那里的情况对他非常不利。因此引用沃莫尔德的话，我认为她带着毫不掩饰的愉悦表达了这一点。他与前情人的亲戚发生了冲突，这极不可能，被丹麦和挪威国王弗雷德里克关入监狱，并于1578年在德拉格斯霍姆城堡去世，我想那里距离哥本哈根约有70英里，被铁链锁在柱子上，精神错乱。哦，对。约翰·盖伊对此有不同的看法。
He thinks that Bothwell was actually quite looked after. But since we're going for the kind of Shakespearean, Jacobian tragedy tone here, let's stick with the fact that he dies mad, chained to a pillar. I mean, another kind of Jacobian tragedy element would. be if somebody were to find some secret letters hidden in a casket. Yes. And sure enough, eight letters and sonnets supposedly written by Mary to Lord Darnley are found in a casket in Holyrood and they are forwarded by Morae to William Sessel.
他认为博斯韦尔其实受到了相当好的照顾。但既然我们追求的是莎士比亚式的雅各布王朝悲剧基调，我们就坚持他发疯、被铁链锁在柱子上死去的说法吧。我的意思是，另一种雅各布王朝悲剧的元素会是，如果有人在暗盒里发现了隐藏的秘密信件。是的。果然，八封据称由玛丽写给达恩利勋爵的信件和十四行诗在荷里路德的一个暗盒里被发现，它们被莫瑞转交给威廉·塞西尔。
And Morae says, they prove, in our opinion, that she consented to the murder of the king, her lawful husband. Do they, Tom? Well, this is obviously unbelievably convenient for Morae and for Cecil. Because they don't really have a case unless they have hard evidence that proves that Mary was implicated in Darnie's murder. So, again, to quote John Guy, who's brilliant on this. The sole evidence that Mary was a party to the murder plot comes from them, so the casket letters. There is no other proof.
而莫瑞说，在我们看来，这些信件证明了她同意谋杀她的合法国王丈夫。是这样吗，汤姆？嗯，这显然对莫瑞和塞西尔来说便利得难以置信。因为除非他们有确凿的证据证明玛丽卷入了达恩利的谋杀案，否则他们根本没有什么案子可言。所以，再次引用约翰·盖伊的话，他在这一点上极其精辟。证明玛丽参与谋杀阴谋的唯一证据来自于他们，也就是那些暗盒信件。没有其他证明。
Her guilt or innocence depends on whether the letters are true or false. And I think that the consensus today is that they probably were faked. I mean, there were so many people on the scene with both motive and opportunity. So if not Moray, then Morton or Maitland. I mean, any of those could have done it. And if they're not faked from scratch, then probably they are repurposed letters. So letters that Mary may genuinely have written that have been kind of edited to make it seem like they're referring to Bothwell. Fair to say that one person who does think the casket letters is Jenny Wurbalt.
她的有罪或无罪取决于这些信件是真是假。我认为今天的共识是它们很可能是伪造的。我的意思是，现场有那么多既有动机又有机会的人。所以如果不是莫瑞，那就是莫顿或梅特兰。我的意思是，任何人都可以做到这一点。如果它们不是从头伪造的，那么它们可能是被挪作他用的信件。也就是玛丽可能真诚写过的信件，经过某种编辑，使它们看起来像是指的是博斯韦尔。可以公平地说，唯一认为暗盒信件是真的的人是珍妮·沃莫尔德。
So she's always keen to think the worse of Mary. But I think, I mean, reading John Guy's kind of comprehensive takedown of the casket letters, I think it's pretty clear they were faked. And one of the things that I think substantiates that is the fact that Elizabeth herself seems to have been sceptical. So also a number of the judges who in October 1568 were appointed to rule on Mary's guilt. So there's this kind of convention. Elizabeth wants to know, well, what's the state of play with them? And one of these judges writes to Cecil and says, this cause is the doubtfulest
所以她总是热衷于把玛丽往坏处想。但我想，阅读了约翰·盖伊对暗盒信件的全面反驳后，我认为很明显它们是伪造的。我认为证实这一点的其中一件事是，伊丽莎白本人似乎也持怀疑态度。还有一些在1568年10月被指派对玛丽的有罪与否做出裁决的法官也是如此。所以有这样一种惯例。伊丽莎白想知道，他们的进展状态如何？其中一位法官写信给塞西尔说，这个案件是最令人捉摸不透的
and the most dangerous that ever I dealt in. Cecil is not happy to be informed of this. So he immediately abolishes the tribunal that's been set up, sets up a new one, and he waits it with judges that he can rely on, including himself. It's not framed as a trial of Mary, but effectively that's what it is. Elizabeth doesn't like this spectacle. She doesn't like the spectacle of commoners sitting in judgment on a monarch. And so at Christmas she adjourns it. It's never reconstituted. The verdict therefore effectively, ironically as a Scottish one, it's the verdict of not proven. And this of course is exactly the kind of verdict that Elizabeth loves. There's no decisive conclusion being made either one way or the other. And it leaves Mary suspended
这也是我处理过的最危险的案子。塞西尔听到这个消息很不高兴。于是他立即废除了已经设立的特别法庭，建立了一个新法庭，并挑选了他可以信赖的法官，包括他自己。这虽然没有被定性为对玛丽的审判，但实际上就是那么回事。伊丽莎白不喜欢这种场面。她不喜欢平民审判君主的场面。因此在圣诞节时，她休庭了。这个法庭再也没有恢复过。因此，这个判决实际上具有讽刺意味的是一个苏格兰式的判决，也就是“罪名未证实”的判决。这当然正是伊丽莎白最喜欢的那种判决。没有做出任何明确的结论，无论是倾向哪一方。这就让玛丽处于一种悬而未决的状态
in a kind of legal no man's land. Is she guilty? Is she isn't? There is no conclusive verdict given. But it means that the taint is there, but Elizabeth doesn't have to act on it. And for Mary, it results in a kind of a living death. You know, she's not convicted,
处于一种法律上的真空地带。她有罪吗？她无罪吗？没有给出最终的结论。但这意味着污点依然存在，而伊丽莎白不必对此采取行动。对玛丽来说，这就变成了一种活生生的折磨。你知道，她没有被定罪，
but Elizabeth isn't going to set her free. And so she, as a result of this, spends the rest of her life effectively under house arrest. But she's not badly treated I mean she's not chained to a pillar She doesn't go mad But she's sort of I mean there's been quite a lot of
但伊丽莎白又不会放她自由。因此，由于这一点，她余下的人生基本上都是在软禁中度过的。但她并没有受到虐待，我是说她没有被锁在柱子上，她也没有发疯，但她有点——我是说，其实有很多
Of house arrest With Tudor queens and princesses Hasn't there under Henry the 8th And then of course what happened to Elizabeth And this is sort of more of the same So she's just kind of She's got an apartment in various houses And she's just
关于都铎王朝王后和公主的软禁经历，不是吗？在亨利八世统治时期，后来当然还有伊丽莎白遭遇的那些。这其实就是那一套的延续。所以她只是在不同的宅邸里有一套公寓，然后她就
You know Yeah and she's got She's got a sizable number Appropriate to her rank She's got Mary Seton Doing her hair Mary Seaton does go back to Scotland in 1577. So that must have been a devastating moment for Mary Queen of Scots, you know, to lose that
你知道的，是的，而且她拥有符合她身份的相当数量的随从。她有玛丽·西顿帮她梳头。玛丽·西顿在1577年回到了苏格兰。对苏格兰女王玛丽来说，这一定是个毁灭性的时刻，你知道的，失去了与她童年的
last link with her childhood. There's basically there's no dancing. There's no fun. Mary loves her sport. So there are all these unfounded stories that she played golf. The evidence on that actually seems to be quite weak. But definitely, I mean, she enjoyed, she enjoyed archery. She enjoyed riding.
最后的联系。基本上就是没有舞蹈，没有娱乐。玛丽热爱运动。所以有很多关于她打高尔夫球的无端传言。但实际上这方面的证据似乎相当薄弱。不过毫无疑问，我是说，她喜欢射箭，她喜欢骑马。
She can't really ride. And so as a result, she, you know, she'd always been very fit. now she starts to get overweight, her shoulders start to stoop, she starts to kind of lose her youthful looks. And of course she's separated from her son, who she knows is being raised in Scotland as a Protestant. And she has to presume that he's being raised to hate her, which is exactly what is indeed happening.
她其实已经不能骑马了。因此，她——你知道的，她以前身体一直很好，现在她开始发胖，双肩开始下垂，她开始失去她青春的容貌。当然，她与她的儿子骨肉分离，她知道儿子在苏格兰是作为新教徒抚养长大的。她只能猜想儿子被灌输了恨她的思想，而这确实就是正在发生的事情。
Do you think she, I mean, she must still have dreamed of returning to Scotland and there are moments of hope, aren't there? So in 1570, Moray, her great arch rival, he was actually assassinated, wasn't he, by one of her supporters? Yes, and not only assassinated, but shot by a firearm. And he is the first head of government ever to be shot with a firearm. So Moray stands at the head of a list, you know, that will include Abraham Lincoln, who will be doing an episode on.
你觉得她——我的意思是，她肯定还梦想着回到苏格兰，而且也有过希望的时刻，对吧？所以在1570年，她的死对头莫雷，实际上是被暗杀了，不是吗？被她的支持者之一？是的，而且不仅被暗杀，还是被火枪射杀的。他是历史上第一个被火枪射杀的政府首脑。所以莫雷在名单上名列前茅，你知道的，这个名单以后还会包括亚伯拉罕·林肯，我们很快就会为他做一期节目。
Very soon. Yes, so Moray gets shot on the 23rd of January, 1570. John Knox preaches at his funeral. By this point, Knox has slightly disgraced himself. So a theme of this series has been middle-aged men having inappropriate relationships with much younger girls. And Knox had married a distant member of the Stuart family who was aged 17 when he, aged 54, married us. So a slight blot on his copy book there. Asquithian level behaviour.
非常快。是的，所以莫雷在1570年1月23日被枪杀。约翰·诺克斯在他的葬礼上布道。此时的诺克斯已经有点声誉扫地了。所以这个系列的一个主题就是中年男子与年轻得多的女孩发展不当关系。诺克斯娶了一位斯图亚特家族的远亲，后者17岁时，54岁的他娶了她。所以他的履历上算是一个小污点。阿斯奎特级别的行为。
Anyway, he's still very much on the scene. He preaches at Murray's funeral and then he dies two years later, happy in the knowledge that the Reformation is secure and that the Catholic Jezebel has been exiled from Scotland. Well, he's had a great time. I mean, that's all worked out right now. It's all worked out well for him. With Murray's death, Scotland collapses into civil war
无论如何，他仍然活跃在政坛上。他在莫雷的葬礼上布道，然后在两年后去世，带着一种满足感死去：宗教改革已经稳固，天主教的耶洗别已经被逐出苏格兰。好吧，他过得很滋润。我的意思是，这一切现在都如愿以偿了。这一切对他的发展都很顺利。随着莫雷的死，苏格兰陷入了内战
between adherence of James and adherence of Mary. Maitland, who has been a shadowy figure. He's kind of siding with Mary. then turning against her. Now he does side with Mary again. So declares for the Marian cause. Lennox and Morton lead the King's Party. Lennox briefly rules as regent before he too is shot, not assassinated this time, but in a skirmish. And by this point, Elizabeth has intervened on the side of her godson James. So against the Marians. And with this English backing, the Marians are comprehensively defeated. There is now no constituency in Scotland able to fight. for Mary's restoration. And among the Merian captives who were handed over by the English to Morton
在詹姆斯的追随者和玛丽的追随者之间。梅特兰一直是个隐秘的人物。他有时站在玛丽一边，然后又背叛她。现在他又站在玛丽一边了。因此宣布支持玛丽的事业。伦诺克斯和莫顿领导国王党。伦诺克斯短暂地担任摄政王，随后他也遭到枪击，这次不是被暗杀，而是在一场冲突中丧生。此时，伊丽莎白已经以其神子詹姆斯的代理人身份进行了干预。也就是对抗拥护玛丽的派别。在英国人的支持下，拥护玛丽的派别遭到彻底击败。苏格兰现在没有任何政治力量能够为主张恢复玛丽的王位而战了。而在英国人移交给莫顿的玛丽派俘虏中
is his old mucker, Maitland. And Morton, of course, shows no mercy at all. He's absolutely set on having Maitland publicly executed. Maitland is thrown into a cell in Edinburgh. The story is that he plays the Roman,
就有他的老搭档梅特兰。而莫顿当然毫不手软。他下定决心要将梅特兰公开处决。梅特兰被扔进爱丁堡的一间牢房里。传说他是像罗马人那样死去的，
i.e. he commits suicide rather than suffer the disgrace of public execution. His body is left in the cell where it is largely devoured by rats. Exactly. So that's Maitland gone, a very jacobian tragedy ending for him. Morton himself now rules as regent, does so throughout the 1570s, makes a very good fist of it.
也就是说他选择了自杀，而不是忍受公开处决的耻辱。他的尸体被遗弃在牢房里，大半被老鼠啃食了。确实如此。所以梅特兰就这样谢幕了，对他来说这是一个极具詹姆斯时期风格的悲剧结局。莫顿本人现在以摄政王身份统治，整个15世纪70年代都是如此，他把国家治理得相当不错。
I mean, he's sinister, but he's very able. Yeah. He does a very good job. But of course he has so many enemies that his, I think his ultimate downfall doesn't really come as a surprise. So on the 31st December 1580, he's confronted in counsel by the brother-in-law of John Knox. So this is the guy who's, you know, he's a kind of steward. And he publicly accuses Morton of complicity in Darnley's murder. So the mystery of Darnley's murder is still kind of floating there, capable of doing damage to big players in Scottish politics.
我是说，他阴险狡诈，但他能力极强。是的。他干得非常出色。但当然他树敌太多，所以他的最终垮台，我认为其实并不让人感到意外。所以在1580年12月31日，他在议事会上遭到约翰·诺克斯小舅子的质问。所以这个人就是，你知道的，他某种程度上也是个管家。他公开指控莫顿参与了谋杀达利。所以达利谋杀案的谜团依然悬而未决，随时可能对苏格兰政坛的重量级人物造成致命打击。
This precipitates Morton's fool. He's put on trial. He's found guilty. he's executed on the 2nd of June 1581. And Dominic, he is executed in a brilliant way. He's basically guillotined. So long before the invention of the guillotine, the Scots had this contraption, which they called the maiden, a kind of proto-gillotine. And it stood in the public square in Edinburgh for a long time, right the way up into the 18th century, I think. And people who are interested can go to the National Museum of Scotland and see it to this day.
这加速了莫顿的倒台。他被交付审判。他被判有罪。他于1581年6月2日被处决。多米尼克，他是以一种非常精彩的方式被处决的。他基本上是被断头台处决的。早在断头台发明很久以前，苏格兰人就有这样一种装置，他们称之为“少女”，是一种原始的断头台。它在爱丁堡的公共广场上伫立了很长时间，一直延续到18世纪，我想是的。感兴趣的人可以去苏格兰国家博物馆亲眼看看。
So if you want to get up close to the fate of Morton, you can go and do that. Well, talking of people going to Scotland and seeing Mary Queen of Scott's themed sites, you're planning to do that yourself, aren't you? In a special bonus episode for our rest is history club members. I've been so enthused by this story that I'm going to go on a tour. We're going to talk about it once I've done it. Yeah, that's the end of Morton. The truth, though, for Mary is that there is really no chance now.
所以如果你想近距离了解莫顿的命运，你可以去看看。好吧，说到人们去苏格兰参观以苏格兰女王玛丽为主题的景点，你自己也正打算这么做，不是吗？这是为我们“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员制作的特别花絮节目。我对这个故事太着迷了，以至于我要去实地旅行一番。等我参观回来后，我们再来聊聊。好吧，莫顿的故事就到这里。然而，对玛丽来说，现实是现在真的已经没有任何机会了。
So in 1580, there is no chance now that she will ever get. get back to her throne in Scotland. She no longer has a party that supports her. Elizabeth clearly is not going to help her. And what happens in the story of the next few years, which we will be doing in a second season on Mary Queen of Scots, but we'll also be looking at Elizabeth I and her spy masters and all the conspiracies and stuff.
所以在1580年，她再也没有任何机会能够回到她在苏格兰的王位上了。她不再拥有支持她的政治派别。伊丽莎白显然不会帮她。而在接下来的几年里，故事将如何发展——我们将在关于苏格兰女王玛丽的第二季中继续讲述，但我们也会关注伊丽莎白一世、她的间谍头子以及所有的阴谋诡计等等。
Basically what she does is she doubles down on her Catholicism, doesn't she? She sort of reinvents herself as the, as the hope of English Catholics, and I suppose Scottish Catholics as well. Yeah, and important to emphasise that Mary has not shown herself to be a true daughter of the Catholic Church. We talked in a previous episode about how odd it is that the Catholic Mary had presided over a Protestant Reformation. And even when she's in captivity in England, she starts kind of flirting with Anglicanism because she thinks that this might. play well with Elizabeth. But once she's realized that there is, you know, Elizabeth has intervened in Scotland against her party, she thinks, I'm going for this. I'm going to play the
基本上她所做的是，她坚定了自己对天主教的信仰，不是吗？她某种程度上将自己重新塑造成了英国天主教徒的希望，我想也是苏格兰天主教徒的希望。是的，而且必须强调的是，玛丽并没有表现出自己是天主教教会的真正女儿。我们在之前的节目中讨论过，天主教徒玛丽竟然主持了一场新教改革，这多么诡异。甚至当她在英国被囚禁时，她开始对英国国教产生某种好感，因为她认为这可能会
role of the Catholic heir to England. And I'm going to try and win the Catholics of England over to my cause. And this is obviously a very, very dangerous policy to adopt. And it is recognized as such right from the very beginning of her captivity in England. So as early as 1772, her erstwhile brother-in-law, the French king, Charles X 11th, had predicted what Mary's fate might be. The poor fool he had written will never cease from plotting until she loses her head. In faith they will put her to death. I see it is her own fault and folly. Well, do you know what? He wasn't wrong. But yes, we'll come back to that story. We'll tell you what happened next to Mary and all the plots and stuff
对取悦伊丽莎白有所帮助。但一旦她意识到，伊丽莎白已经在苏格兰干预并反对她的党羽时，她想，豁出去了。我要扮演
in a future series. And of course, rest is history. Club members will be able to hear the episodes of that series early. But Tom, before we just, before we say goodbye, let's, we've got Mary out of Scotland. So let's look back at her time in Scotland and her time as the Queen of Scots. Now, some historians, let's say Jenny Wormold, he had mentioned a lot, say, look, this is a woman who, you know, maybe she was dealt a bad ham. and there were lots of terrible people around her but she played her cards incredibly poorly she made poor decisions she was irresponsible
英国天主教继承人的角色。我要试图把英国的天主教徒争取到我的事业中来。这显然是一个非常非常危险的政治策略。而且从她被囚禁在英国的一开始，人们就意识到了这一点。早在1572年，她昔日的小舅子、法国国王查理九世就曾预言过玛丽的命运可能会怎样。这个可怜的傻瓜，他曾写道，只要她不砍头就绝不会停止密谋。相信我，他们会处死她的。我看这完全是她自作自受和愚蠢。好吧，你知道吗？他说得没错。不过是的，我们会回到这个故事中。我们会告诉你们玛丽接下来遭遇了什么，以及所有的阴谋诡计
she was lazy she was just politically inept and do you know what I mean I know Jamie Wilmold really dislikes her but can you really disagree with a lot of that I mean she does play she makes terrible choices again and again no so there are two layers here one of the layers is
在未来的系列节目中。当然，“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员将能够提前听到该系列节目的单集。但是汤姆，在我们道别之前，我们已经把玛丽送出了苏格兰。所以让我们回顾一下她在苏格兰的时光，以及她作为苏格兰女王的时光。现在，一些历史学家，比方说珍妮·沃莫尔德，她曾多次提到，看，这是一个女人，你知道的，也许她拿到了一手烂牌，
the issue of whether Mary was conspiring against Darnley to murder him, whether she had been having an adulterous affair with Bothwell, the level of the murders, the marriages, the rapes, the conspiracies, the assassinations, which has always provided the kind of the colour and the glamour and the tragedy of Mary Queen of Scots and explains why she is such an extraordinary figure,
周围有很多可怕的人，但她打这副牌打得糟糕透顶，她做出了糟糕的决定，她不负责任
why people have been so fascinated by her, why so many dramatists and librettists and film directors have seen in her the kind of the perfect heroine for a drama. I think that Jenny Wormald is unfair on the Mary Queen of Scots of that layer. However, the layer that Jenny Wormald, as a historian looking at the kind of deep structures of the Scottish state in the 15th and 16th centuries, I think she writes with a sense of horror
她很懒惰，在政治上简直无能，你知道我的意思吗？我知道珍妮·沃莫尔德真的很讨厌她，但你真的能反驳她的很多观点吗？我的意思是，她确实一再做出糟糕的选择，对吧？所以这里有两个层面，其中一个层面是
at just how disastrous Mary Queen of Scots was. She has studied Mary Queen of Scots predecessors who are very able, very competent, very hard ruling, if you like. And Mary exhibits none of those qualities and her ability to make the wrong decision again and again and again is just extraordinary. And that is not to downplay the tragedy of her fate.
关于玛丽是否曾密谋谋杀达利，她是否曾与博斯韦尔有通奸关系，谋杀、婚姻、强奸、阴谋、暗杀的程度——这些一直为苏格兰女王玛丽的故事提供了某种色彩、魅力和悲剧色彩，也解释了为什么她是一个如此非凡的人物，
the horrors that have visited on her. But I think it is to say that as Queen of Scots, she is a failure. And that's patent because she only lasts six years. Yeah. What else could she be defined as? A quick question, though, some listeners may say,
为什么人们对她如此着迷，为什么那么多戏剧家、剧作家和电影导演都在她身上看到了戏剧完美女主角的影子。我认为珍妮·沃莫尔德对那一层面的苏格兰女王玛丽是有失公允的。然而，珍妮·沃莫尔德作为一名历史学家，从15和16世纪苏格兰国家深层结构的视角来看，我认为她在写作时带着一种惊恐之感
of course, it's much harder for her being a woman. My counterarguments to that would be that actually, I mean, England in the same period, has two actually pretty proficient female. I mean, I know everybody disses bloody Mary, Mary the first. But, you know, she does rule competently. And of course, Elizabeth I first is very competent. So it's not impossible to be a competent woman faced by challenges and to surmount them.
惊叹于苏格兰女王玛丽是多么的灾难深重。她研究过苏格兰女王玛丽的前任们，那些人都极具能力、极为能干，可以说是铁腕统治。而玛丽身上却没有展现出这些品质，她一次又一次、一次又一次做出错误决策的能力简直非同寻常。这并不是要贬低她命运的悲剧色彩，
And also, of course, in France, there is Mary Queen of Scott's mother-in-law, Catherine D' Medici, who isn't a regnant queen. But she is a very, very formidable player and who is prepared to take very robust action when her interests need defending, namely slaughtering enormous numbers of Protestants on the streets of Paris. Mary Queen of Scots never countenance as that. And, of course, people may be listening to this and thinking, well, you're saying she's a failure because she didn't sanction repression, violent, bloody repression. I mean, in a sense, that is what we're saying because that was what was expected of Queens in the 16th century. And those are the standards by which we are judging Mary. I think Mary was a nicer person than Elizabeth or Catherine de Medici. I think she was kind-hearted. She did not tend to pursue her enemies. She was, for giving. But I think that was precisely the problem. So as a human being, I think she is a very attractive person. But as a queen, I think she's a failure. Okay. Well, maybe on that note, Tom, we should look ahead. We will be returning with the rest of Mary Queen of Scots' story in a few months' time, I think. I mean, we often say that. And actually, it turns out to be like six
也不是要否认她所遭受的可怕折磨。但我想说的是，作为苏格兰女王，她是个彻头彻尾的失败者。这是显而易见的，因为她只统治了六年。是的。还能怎么定义她呢？不过有个简单的问题，一些听众可能会说，
years later. But we'll try to do it more quickly, I think. Because you're full of Mary Queen of Scott's themed enthusiasm, won't you? I certainly am, and not only Mary Queen of Scots themed enthusiasm. I'm also very enthusiastic about Cecil's spy network, Sir Francis Walsingham, counter espionage, all of that. It's very John Le Carre, so we will be
当然，作为一个女人，她的处境要艰难得多。我的反驳论点是，实际上，英国在同一时期，也有两个相当出色的女性统治者。我是说，我知道所有人都贬低血腥玛丽，也就是玛丽一世。但是，你知道的，她确实统治得很能干。当然，伊丽莎白一世也非常能干。所以，面对挑战并克服它们，成为一个能干的女性并不是不可能做到的。
looking at that, and at Mary's ultimate fate. And do you know what it all sets the scene for? That's something we've been building up to doing on the rest of history. The Spanish Armada. Yes, it does. Yes, it does. So that will be hopefully setting sail next year. I don't understand why people wouldn't join the Restis History Club after hearing that.
而且当然，在法国，还有苏格兰女王玛丽的婆婆凯瑟琳·德·美第奇，她虽然不是女王，但她是一个非常非常强大的政治玩家，当需要捍卫自身利益时，她随时准备采取非常强硬的行动，也就是在巴黎街头屠杀大量新教徒。苏格兰女王玛丽从未赞同过这一点。当然，听到这里的人可能会想，你们说她是失败者，是因为她没有批准镇压，那种充满暴力的血腥镇压。从某种意义上说，这确实就是我们的意思，因为这就是16世纪对女王的要求，而这就是我们评判玛丽的标准。我认为玛丽比伊丽莎白或凯瑟琳·德·美第奇是个更好的人。我认为她心地善良。她没有刻意去迫害她的敌人。她总是心存原谅。但我想这恰恰是问题所在。所以作为一个活生生的人，我认为她非常有魅力。但作为一个女王，我认为她是失败的。好吧，也许就凭这一点，汤姆，我们应该展望未来。我想我们将在几个月后带着苏格兰女王玛丽故事的剩余部分回归。我的意思是，我们经常这么说。但实际上结果往往是大约六年
That is madness. Just to remind you, it's the rest is history.com. It's what Mary, Queen of Scots, would have wanted. And that bombshell, Tom, thank you so much.
之后。但我认为我们会试着更快地推出。因为你充满了以苏格兰女王玛丽为主题的热情，不是吗？我当然是的，而且不仅是关于苏格兰女王玛丽的主题热情。我对塞西尔的间谍网、弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士、反间谍活动所有这些也都充满了热情。这非常具有约翰·勒卡雷的风格，所以我们将拭目以待，并关注玛丽最终的命运。你知道这一切是在为铺垫什么吗？那是我们一直在《历史其余部分》节目中为此努力的事情。西班牙无敌舰队。是的，正是如此。是的，正是如此。所以希望明年它就能扬帆起航。我不明白为什么听了这些之后会有人不加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部。
That was an absolute toward the force. I think you've ever heard that before. Thank you very much. Splendid stuff. Bye by, everybody. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是绝对的力量。我想你以前从未听过这个。非常感谢。太棒了。大家再见。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。